[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie toss
a coin to your witcher this is going to
be my new witcher netflix season 2 video
and a big breakdown of the jason momoa
announcement so you may have seen some
of the news the past couple of days i'll
explain what's going on
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
actually a bunch of witcher
projects that netflix is doing in
addition to season two there's also an
anime movie called nightmare of the wolf
in a prequel called witcher blood origin
which is going to detail the origin of
the witcher order
so we'll just start with the big stuff
first the jason momoa news you may have
seen the past couple weeks that netflix
is trying to cast jason momoa in the
witcher netflix jason momoa seemingly
confirmed this by posting this fan art
to his instagram story
saying hey brother talking to henry
cavill's geralt obviously
so naturally everybody freaked out
because it'd be awesome to see them
reunite inside the world of the witcher
netflix because they're both big dc
characters in the dc movies in justice
league we're going to see them together
again in the justice league snyder cut
with a whole bunch of new footage next
year too
but here's the thing they're not casting
him for the witcher netflix season 2.
they're in production for that right now
i'll explain what's going on with
witcher season 2 in a second
but netflix is actually trying to cast
him for the witcher blood
origin series so number four if you
don't know what that is
that's basically the origin of the
witchers so jason mamoa would basically
be
the very first witcher so far the
witcher story in the novels or the games
hasn't really explained
who that first witcher was we know a
little bit about the origins of the
witchers and the people who first
created the witcher mutations
i'm going to read the description that
the showrunner gave for this series so
it'll give you a pretty good idea for
what it's going to cover
in terms of history he says a question
has been burning in my mind ever since i
first read the witcher books
what was the elven world like before the
cataclysmic arrival of humans i've
always been fascinated by the rise and
fall of civilizations
how science discovery and culture
flourish right before that fall
how swaz of knowledge are lost forever
in such a short time
often compounded by the colonization and
rewriting of history
leaving only fragments of a
civilization's true story behind
the witcher blood origin will tell the
tale of the elven civilization before
its fall
and most importantly reveal the
forgotten history of the very first
witcher so that's why it seems like it's
going to be so easy for them to land
jason mamoa and jason momoa himself has
done a bunch of other netflix series so
it's not unusual for him to do mini
series or
big series like this with streamers the
actual witcher blood origin series is
only supposed to be six episodes long
and
basically netflix's strategy for the
witcher netflix franchise in general not
just the main series with henry cappel
is that it sounds like they're actually
going to be doing obviously multiple
seasons to cover all the witcher books
and novels
but between those seasons they're going
to fill the gaps with
miniseries with other stories other
witcher's stories
like that's where the anime movie the
nightmare of the wolf comes in
that's gonna deal a lot with the origins
of vesamir when he was much younger
before
geralt came along and he had to deal
with this really really horrific
adventure
number three here's the thing though we
actually know a lot about that period
that they're dealing with it was about a
thousand years before the events on the
main show right now
if you're not familiar with the history
of the world in the witcher
humans actually did not come from the
planet that the witcher series takes
place on or the games
they actually came from somewhere else
in the multiverse a planet called
quote-unquote earth
so the planet that we're on and all the
games and all the books is not earth
the way the author talks about the books
he said that originally he had actually
intended for the world that the series
takes place on to be a version of
prehistoric earth but then he changed
his mind
because if you're not familiar with the
lore of the witcher there is time travel
there is
travel through the multiverse so it is
kind of a science fiction and fantasy
story together
so the cataclysmic event that they talk
about that brought humans from earth
to the world of the witcher is actually
called the conjunction of the spheres
which is something that the show is
actually building up towards again it's
the cyclical event
the key to all this is series character
but they actually did this
short movie inside the games where they
explained this whole history so i'll
play the clip from that here
i'm past our world intertwined with
another through an upheaval
scholars call the conjunction of the
spheres
the gods allowed unholy forces to slip
into our demand
the offspring of that cataclysm was the
nefarious force
called magic
yet we did not banish it instead
studying the file arcane
for our own power and wealth
and the monsters at our door the
unholy relics of this conjunction
the trolls the corpse eaters the
werewolves
did we raise our swords against them
oh have we laid this burden on others
once so so-called witches
stray children taught the ways of foul
sorcery
their bodies mutated through blasphemous
ritual
incentified monsters though they could
not distinguish good from evil the
flicker of humanity
long extinguished within them
yes their numbers have dwindled through
the years
but a few still roam our lands the way
they talk about
the conjunction of the spheres during
that clip is actually basically when
planets come into alignment and it
allows
other people from places in the
multiverse other worlds to cross over
into the world of the witcher and within
the context of this clip
they're just talking about monsters
coming to the world of the witcher
that's where monsters came from the
multiverse they used the conjunction of
the spheres to cross over but that's
also what humans did a long time ago
so if you watch the witcher netflix
season one then you basically seen
what's happened to elves in present day
they're slowly going
extinct even though there's this ancient
race a lot of their history has been
lost through all these wars with
humanity
they've been kicked off their lands
there's the threat of another war coming
again in present day
most of this we get through geralt's
perspective because we're following him
around through the story
number two the origin of the witchers in
the witcher schools is talked about a
little bit
piecemeal throughout the different books
so you don't get all that history in one
big jump right at the beginning
like a lot of big world building fantasy
authors you don't get all the story
right away we learn a little bit about
the mages that created the witcher
mutations during season of storms
according to scholars it was the
legendary mages cosimo and his
apprentice who actually created the
mutations
we don't know a lot about the person
that they tested those on
but based on what netflix is planning
here it sounds like it would be that
very first witcher played by jason momoa
we don't know what his name is it's not
recorded in history
and even cooler his apprentice after
this went on to become even more famous
in his own right creating a lot of the
most powerful spells that tris and
yennefer wind up using in the books and
the games in present day
there were only a couple scenes during
the witcher netflix season one where you
actually see henry cavill taking his
witcher potions we got a little bit of
it during the trailer but i'm sure
there's a bunch of footage that wound up
on the cutting room
floor they actually just dropped a big
behind-the-scenes
witcher netflix season one series as
well it's sort of like extra bonus
material about the making of the witcher
netflix episodes
but the really cool thing about all this
the conjunction of the spheres travel
between the multiverse obviously the
origin of the witcher series the origin
of humans in the world of the witcher
is that siri is actually the key to sort
of connecting all these different
series in all these different time
periods they only hinted at siri in her
elder blood powers a little bit
during season one but she is god tear
powerful
she can open portals to anywhere she
wants to go to
in time and space it's almost like a
doctor who situation
no joke within the world of the story in
the novels
she has actually traveled to different
time periods and been to that original
earth in the multiverse that humans came
from
the way the author talks about the
original planet he just talks about how
humans basically trashed earth
so bad that they were forced to cross
over into the world of the witcher and
that was their last ditch attempt to
find some place to live that wasn't
destroyed
so a big theme of the witcher series
that kind of plays out a little bit in
the background during season one
is that sometimes humans are just as bad
if not worse than the monsters that they
hire geralt to fight
so often times geralt finds himself
protecting the monsters more than the
humans
this whole backstory that they're going
to tell with the witcher blood origin
series about humans coming and basically
taking over all the elves in the elder
races
lands is gonna do a much better job of
showcasing that like look how terrible
these people are i don't know if we're
gonna see siri jumping around in time
and space during season two or anything
like that it's a little early for
something like that she doesn't even
understand her powers even in the books
when she gets older and she accidentally
starts jumping around
portaling through time and space she
doesn't totally understand how she does
it
what's happening right now though is
that during season two at least at the
beginning of the season we'll see them
go back to kare moren because that's
where they're headed now that he's found
siri
they'll begin training her as a witcher
even though she doesn't take the
mutations like geralt does
the reason why she doesn't take the
mutations is because there's no one left
alive that they know of that can create
the potions that they need to undergo
the witcher mutations in the trial of
the grasses
so even if someone wanted to become a
witcher they wouldn't be able to fully
become a true witcher the way that
geralt in vesemir are witchers
that's okay though siri is so powerful
she does not need to undergo the witcher
mutations in order to be an effective
witcher
right now just based on their production
timeline i don't know if they're going
to be able to get episodes out by the
end of next year it'll be a race to the
finish if they do so it's always
possible we get episodes by next
december in 2021
everyone let me know in the comments
what do you think about jason momoa
coming to the world of the witcher
it just sounds really cool it seems like
he'd actually fit in really well
speaking of jason mamow and henry cavill
crossover there's another big dc fandom
event that's coming up with a bunch of
new justice league snyder cut
batman dc movie stuff you can click here
for the trailer for that learn what's
going on
and click here for all my witcher
netflix episode videos
thank you so much for watching everyone
toss a coin to your witcher i'll see you
guys tonight
you